60 minutes rewind.
Say Denzel and most people would know you're talking about one of the highest paid and
most popular actors in Hollywood.
But 30 years ago Denzel Washington was just another unknown struggling New York actor.
Today he's playing the lead in a Broadway play and making standard union wages, a fraction
of what he'd make in Hollywood.
So we went to see him and I remember the story he told me five years ago about an incredible
prediction that he says started it all.
I was in my mother's beauty shop and I was looking in the mirror and I saw a woman sitting
across the room for me.
And she said to my mother, bring me a piece of paper.
She's got a prophecy.
It's the guy's honest truth.
I got the piece of paper and I keep it with me all the time.
And she wrote down, she said this boy is going to speak to millions of people.
I don't talk about that a lot but I've kind of felt like well maybe I have some job to
do.
Remember the woman I tell you about the prophecy?
That was 30 years, that will be 30 years ago next week.
Right.
And then I started acting that fall.
So it's kind of interesting coming back now 30 years later, about 20 blocks from where
I started.
Roman's country made it.
Dins our Washington's career began on the obscure stage at New York's Fordham University.
But today he is headlining on Broadway appearing in a modern day production of Shakespeare's
Julius Caesar.
He plays Brutus, one of the leaders of a plot to kill Caesar.
Not that I love Caesar less.
But that I love Rome more.
Why did you decide to do this play now?
I thought it was a great opportunity to get back on the stage, to get back to my roots.
And I get so few opportunities to get on the stage.
So when I do I really like tackling Shakespeare which is the toughest and the most rewarding.
There is no terror in castles in your threats.
I mean it took me 30 years but I'm finally doing what I wanted to do when I started.
The actors I started with in college and we were all snobs and we thought we would make
$600 a week in on Broadway or whatever it was back then.
We didn't think about going to Hollywood.
That was some Hollywood.
You didn't do that.
But he did.
And it is his acting in those Hollywood movies that has made Dins our Washington a household
name.
He's been in more than 30 feature films in one two Academy Awards.
Best supporting actor for his portrayal of a runaway slave in the film Glory.
And in 2002, best actor for his performance as the dirty cop Alonzo Harris in training
day.
I ain't holding no hands.
I understand I ain't babysitting.
You got today.
And today I'm going to show me who and what you made of.
His name has become synonymous with Hollywood box office blockbusters.
Most recently he played Major Ben Marco in a remake of the Manchurian candidate.
Somebody got into our heads with big steel toe boots.
The cable cut isn't a chain so they went to town.
You've been working a lot since we talked five years ago.
You've done what?
Seven films since then?
Ever?
Since what year was it?
29.
Okay.
I mean, it's a lot of work.
Uh, is it?
I mean, work is like, you know, garbage man is work.
I'm acting is not work.
Acting is a privilege and it's a craft and all of those things, but it's not work.
I read that you got 20 million in film now.
I heard you make that kind of money too.
I'm not there yet.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you finished.
I thought I was just getting started.
I wanted to tell you something, son, to me, I slipped your mind.
But you are dressing the superior officer.
You want to stand me?
In 2002, in the film Antoine Fisher, Denzel played a Navy psychiatrist counseling a troubled
sailor.
Cut, cut, okay.
In addition, tackling a new role as the film's director.
I want you to face right in our face that's for our first shot, you know?
Did you enjoy, director?
Absolutely.
I'm going to do it again.
When it comes to one or the other, I mean, you'd like to do both or do you prefer acting
over directing?
Um, I look at Clint Eastwood as the model.
That's, I like the way he's doing things and that's how I'd like to do it.
Just segue right on into more and more filmmaking.
A Hollywood director's chair is a long way from where he grew up in Mount Vernon, a working
class suburb outside New York City.
His mother, Lenis, managed that beauty shop.
His father, Denzel Sr., was a Pentecostal preacher who held down two other jobs.
Denzel went to church every Sunday, but dreamed of becoming a professional athlete.
He spent all of his free time here at what was then the boys club.
This was an important place for you.
Yep.
I lived here.
My mother had to come get me.
So you had a time when you had to come home?
Nine o'clock, man.
I had a time.
I knew I had to get to the fish market by 8.54 and buy the chicken joint by 8.56 in order
to make it home by nine o'clock.
Did she ever have to come looking for you?
She did.
She would.
We were in the park and she came.
And we were like, oh, I see your mom's here and I got in the car and she was screaming.
So I kind of look at everybody.
I have to window like, you know, I got this.
As I was, as I was turning around, pow!
So I put my head under the dashboard.
Just drive, mom.
Just drive.
Denzel says his mother, Lenna, saved his life when she scraped together enough money
to send him to Oakland Academy, a small boarding school for boys in upstate New York.
He hadn't been back there for 20 years and was surprised to see his old school being
converted into condominiums.
Man, it looks so little now.
My God.
Denzel was 14 when he came here, one of only a handful of African American students.
How did you end up here?
I was in a public school, my mother in high school.
And my mother decided it was best to get me out of there before I ended up where a lot
of my friends are now in the grave, in the penitentiary.
How were you up here?
I mean, were you a bad kid?
No.
Angrier as time went along.
What were you angry about?
Come on, let's take a walk in here.
Right about here was a chair.
And I was sitting in the messelor, whatever we called it.
And they told me, your mother's here.
And I said, my mother's here.
I said, oh, what did I do?
I did something wrong.
And I came right about here, sat down.
And she said, your father and I aren't together anymore.
You're going to be with me.
You know, I don't know what I'm going to do, but we're going to work it out.
So this is where I found out my parents were getting divorced, right here, right here,
right here, right here.
I remember it like it was yesterday.
So to answer your question about anger, I think I started getting a little trouble after
that, started getting in fights.
And I almost kicked out of school, but his mother talked the headmaster into giving
him another chance.
You owe her a lot.
I owe her everything.
I assume you told her that.
In many ways.
The story will continue after this.
And so I made the most of that second chance, building a career that has brought him riches,
fame and critical acclaim.
So why would an actor who makes millions for one movie risk his reputation by taking a
role that pays $1,700 a week?
What do you get out of it?
I mean, when you go through this performance, eight times a week.
It's like retooling.
The lights come up, the curtain goes up, and it's an actor's medium on stage.
And you know, it's flying by the seat of your pants.
You got to keep going.
It's live.
Things happen.
We're still going through things.
Things fall.
Lights don't work.
You forget lines or whatever happens.
And that's good.
That's good exercise.
Cell phones go off.
One of these days, I'm going to respond to it in Iambic pentameter.
Answer it that.
My lord.
My lord, it is for you.
I'm going to be a man.
This production has traded ancient rooms, togas and tunics for suits, ties, and camouflage.
It is set in modern times and is intended to be evocative of power struggles in cities
like Washington or Baghdad.
What makes the play Julius Caesar relevant today?
Well, okay.
I mean, it's what ifs.
We do have leaders in the world that think they're gods.
I mean, it's not just governments.
It's corporations.
It's, you know, unfortunately, not a lot has changed.
I think it's a part of the human condition.
Julius Caesar opened two weeks ago to mixed reviews.
But Denzel says reviews don't affect him because he doesn't read them.
Anyway, the show is nearly sold out for his scheduled 112 performances that will run
until June.
Performances that give him something he doesn't get in Hollywood.
What do you feel at the end of a performance?
I mean, this is not an easy role.
Thankful.
You know, I run off stage or wipe the makeup off.
I say a quick prayer.
I hear the people out there clap and you get a sense.
Is it two bows tonight?
Is it one?
Is it three?
You know?
But a relief, you know?
Joy?
You don't get that in the movies.
Making movies.
All the feelings I'm getting night after night, I mean, people are like, man, you got 100
to go, but I'm like, yeah, I'm enjoying every one of them.